Welcome back everyone this is my new thor
loving thunder video marvel just released
a new first look at rune king thor in some of
the other major characters costumes including
christian bale's gorr the godbutcher costume
valkyrie and lady thor's full armor and what the
reforged mjolnir hammer is going to look like so
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos i know everybody's
been asking when are they gonna finally do
rune king thor in the mcu most powerful version
of thor ever he's almost too powerful to use in
a story so i'll try to explain how i think they're
adapting his storyline just based on what they're
pitching us in this new promo the other funny
thing about thor love and thunder is that it's
actually the first big marvel phase 4 movie that
isn't directly influenced or tied to the events
of spider-man no way home there is a little bit
of timeline overlap that i'll explain but like
it's hard to talk about doctor strange multiverse
of madness without talking about what happened in
spider-man no way home but all the stuff that's
going on with gorr the god butcher the guardians
of the galaxy the asgardians of the galaxy doesn't
really have anything to do with doctor strange's
spells either the first one or the second one or
any of the multiverse characters from no way home
so no worries if you have not seen spider-man
no way home yet i know there's still a couple
countries that for some strange reason have
not got the movie yet there was a minor thor
love and thunder easter egg in spider-man no way
home but it's just like a really quick blink and
you'll miss it easter egg it's a daily bugle scene
just referencing political turmoil in new asgard
which is all about valkyrie becoming their
new ruler after avengers end game and how
practically speaking not everybody in new
asgard and the nine realms is happy with the
changes quote unquote that she's making remember
that scene at the end of avengers end game where
she said her whole deal for accepting thor's
offer was that she would be making changes
you know i'd make a lot of changes around here i'm
counting on it your majesty so that's probably why
there's political turmoil during the events of
spider-man no way home and if it wasn't clear
the events of spider-man no way home are supposed
to take place before thor love and thunder doctor
strange multiverse of madness might be happening
around the same time thor and gorr the god butcher
start throwing down usually there's a little
bit of overlap between all the marvel movies
but gorr jane foster lady thor they aren't meant
to be multiverse characters even though spider-man
no way home doctor strange multiverse of madness
are very much multiverse movies thor love and
thunder is going to get more into the mythology
of the gods of the mcu but what it seems like
they're doing with rune king thor just based on
his costume here i'm calling him rune king thor
because clearly his costume is inspired by rune
king thor's costume with the mixture of the blues
and the gold is that during the movie they're just
gonna make thor the most powerful that he's ever
been and that's basically who rune king thor was
supposed to be if you haven't read that run in
the comics it's a fairly self-contained story so
i will explain what happened during the comic book
version and how i think they're going to change
some of that for the movies in that story thor
goes through ragnarok like they did in the mcu
in almost all of his family all of his allies
and friends die and he decides that he must seek
the wisdom of odin so that he can understand how
to become a true god he decides to truly embrace
his potential as a god which was the whole deal
at the end of ragnarok are you the god of hammers
like basically odin was trying to explain to him
that you never needed the hammer you already had
all this power within you the whole time but in
the mcu he went through that whole arc during
avengers infinity war and avengers end game
and was kind of laid low so at the end of avengers
end game he goes with the guardians of the galaxy
the asgardians of the galaxy on a journey of
self-discovery kind of like rune king thor went
on to attain true wisdom so thor is trying to gain
the odin force and the odin force is basically the
combined life energy of odin and his two brothers
it was created when the three of them fought
surtur for the first time odin's brothers died but
odin absorbed their life energy creating the odin
force and that gave him the power up to defeat
surter for the first time they actually referenced
that at the beginning of the thor ragnarok movie
when thor is joking with certain didn't my father
kill you like a million years ago that was
basically the event that created the odin force
shutter son of a you're still alive i thought my
father killed you like a half a million years ago
so after ragnarok odin is dead thor does not have
the odin force the odin force just kind of becomes
this disembodied power just floating around the
universe and it visits thor and explains to him
how he can attain the power that odin had but in
order to do that he has to follow a similar path
but the odin force tells thor do you just want
what odin had or do you want more do you want
to take this further do you want to gain the
full potential of the power that you can wield
so in order to do that he has to sacrifice way
more than odin ever sacrificed and this plays on a
lot of norse mythology tropes he learns that odin
sacrificed one of his eyes to the well of mimir
to gain cosmic knowledge so thor sacrifices both
of his eyes and essentially becomes omniscient he
gains so much cosmic power that he can see through
time he can see all timelines and then gains
the full power of the runes and that's why he's
called rune king thor the runes are basically this
asgardian cosmic artifact that give the wielder
knowledge that he wouldn't normally be able to
obtain and the more you go through the more you
sacrifice the greater access to the runes you have
in the whole idea is that odin was only wielding
the runes at about half of their potential
but thorn sacrificing twice as much as odin gains
twice the power gains full access to the runes so
essentially he goes from being a little g god to
a capital g god like celestial level character
omniscient omnipotent pretty much unkillable
for anyone except for the highest order of
cosmic characters like the beyonder or the one
above all the living tribunal you get the idea
in the comics odin was able to hand galactus ass
so if rune king thor is twice as powerful as odin
was he becomes so powerful he's like a cosmic
entity in his own right now but because that's
too powerful to use in like normal marvel stories
like it's just way too op in order to bring him
back down to normal levels they said that this
ultimate god tier thor basically went into this
cosmic sleep state kind of becoming one with the
universe and eventually a version of odin was
reborn reclaimed the odin force for himself and
then a version of thor returned to earth the nine
realms vastly de-powered so heading into marvel
phase four and beyond chris hemsworth said that
he did want to keep coming back for more marvel
movies as the thor character after thor love
and thunder so i don't think they're gonna do the
exact rune king thor storyline for him like he'll
just become more of a god in the true sense of
the word and embrace more of a grander cosmic role
like he'll start spending more time helping the
entire universe not just asgard and earth cosmic
level threats responsibilities and it'll be a
way of explaining why he's not around for every
single event like oh thor is dealing with cosmic
level problems he doesn't have time to deal with
these small earth level problems and that'll be a
way of explaining how valkyrie can still continue
ruling over asgard because thor is dealing
with even bigger cosmic threats valkyrie's
new costume looks more like a combination of her
white valkyrie armor and thor's armor without the
sleeves like everyone in this movie is going guns
out full on everyone wants you to buy two tickets
to the gun show even natalie portman the metal
pattern at the bottom that looks kind of like
the asgardian version of chainmail also seems like
it's based on the new comic book valkyries costume
who is also jane foster that's right jane foster
is like the newest valkyrie she becomes valkyrie
after she stops being lady thor and wielding
mjolnir jane foster's lady thor costume looks
kind of like a combination of comic book lady thor
and thor's old mcu costumes with a little added
red material just to give it some color and make
it pop a little more on screen the other really
important thing here is mjolnir this confirms
my theory from earlier this year the version of
thor's hammer that she wields is just the original
hammer that reforms itself through its magic or
odin's enchantment notice all the cracks that
are laced with magical energy pouring out that's
the same energy you saw when hella destroyed the
hammer in the movie it seems like the asgardians
create two special shrines here this large shrine
is just the site where odin died on the cliffside
so it's meant to be a memorial to him and they
created another smaller one here at the site where
mjolnir was destroyed like they didn't move the
pieces of the broken hammer they just placed them
on this pedestal here so what they're implying
here in this scene is that something happens in
asgard maybe corey the god butcher shows up
and starts killing a whole bunch of people
and jane foster is standing near odin's memorial
in the pieces of mjolnir and maybe she touches one
of the broken pieces in the magic of the hammer
or odin's original enchantment just deems her
worthy she fulfills the qualifications and that
automatically causes the hammer to reform itself
gives her her powers and her armor the original
enchantment just read whosoever holds this hammer
if they be worthy shall possess the power of thor
so that's a broad enough magical enchantment that
as long as natalie portman's jane foster touches
one of the pieces in in whatever the circumstances
are whatever's going on around this it deems her
worthy and that reactivates it like i said though
she's also guns out and she has the blonde hair
from comic book lady thor the reason why they
did that in the comics though the reason why the
enchantment changed her hair color mostly was a
way to hide her identity because it was meant to
be this big mystery when she was first introduced
like who is this person but since we already know
that it's jane foster in the mcu in the movie they
might not be doing the whole secret identity thing
as for gorr the god butcher's costume this is just
what he looks like on set obviously this is meant
to be a little bit of mocap so they'll tune this
way way up in post-production with special effects
you can kind of see how they're trying to make him
look kind of like comic book gorr with the necro
sword with the way it kind of billows around him
like the sword itself gives him this black cloak
i know that a lot of venom questions too because
of all the recent venom multiverse crossover but i
don't think they're gonna say that the necro sword
in this movie or the power that gorr wields is the
primal symbiote if they want to do that i think
later on they'll just kind of retcon it in quietly
the way they do that every once in a while in the
mcu but everybody let me know in the comments what
do you think about rune king thor's costume in the
movie i know everybody's just excited to see the
most powerful version of thor that you've ever
seen in the mcu they'll probably release the first
thor love and thunder trailer when doctor strange
multiverse of madness his theaters in a couple
months so we should see some more footage from
the movie pretty soon click here for my brand
new doctor strange multiverse of madness video
and click here for my spider-man no way
home alternate ending video in deleted
scenes thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!